hello everyone
i welcome you all to simply learn
in today's session we'll discuss psn's
correlation and how you can use excel
and python to calculate the correlation
coefficient
before we move ahead if you haven't
already subscribed to our channel please
do so so that you never miss on an
update
let's discuss the agenda for today's
session
we'll start by discussing what is
correlation and correlation coefficient
then we'll move on to discuss pierce's
rank correlation and its formula
then we'll move on to excel and python
to see how you can calculate the
pearson's rank correlation coefficient
so what is correlation
the two variables are said to be
correlated if the change in one variable
results in the corresponding change in
another variable
it can be positive or negative
for example
the price and demand of a product are in
correlation as the demand of a product
increases the price increases
simultaneously
the value of the correlation always lies
between minus one to plus one
minus one shows a strong negative
correlation
zero shows that there is no relationship
between the two variables and plus one
shows there is a very strong correlation
between the two variables
some of the examples can be
the time spent on e-commerce website
versus the money spent by the customers
it can be taken as an example of
positive correlation
number of unique users versus sales in a
day are also correlated
correlation can also be used to measure
the patient's blood pressure and the
medication used
now let's discuss what is psn
correlation
pss correlation coefficient is a
statistical test that measures the
relationship or association between the
two continuous variables
it is known as the best method for
measuring the association between the
two variables because it gives the
relationship between the magnitude of
the association as well as the direction
of the relationship
the formula to calculate the psn rank
correlation is r
is equal to sigma x i minus x bar
bracket y i minus y bar divided by under
root of sigma sigma x i minus x bar
whole square y i minus y bar whole
square
in this case r is the coefficient of
correlation x y is the mean of x
variable and y bar is the mean of y
variable
and x i and y are are samples of the
variable x and y
now that we know the pearson's rank
correlation let's move on to excel and
then python to see how you can calculate
this rank correlation coefficient
so here we are on our excel workbook
as you can see we have two columns one
is test scores and others are spent on
studying
we have to find the correlation between
the two
that means how the test scores and the
number of hours spent on studying affect
each other
so to do that we'll first move on to
data tab
and we'll set data analysis
here we'll go on to correlation and
click ok
now it is asking for input range
so here we'll select both the columns as
an input range we have the labels in our
first row so we'll check on the labels
now for the output range we'll give the
output range in the same sheet so
we'll select this results for our output
range we click ok
and now you see the test scores and our
spent on studying are very positively
correlated that is 0.98 which shows a
very strong correlation it means as the
number of hours spent on studying
increases the test score will definitely
increase
there is one more way to calculate the
correlation
using function so
to calculate the correlation between
test scores and ask spent on studying
we'll type equal to
corel tab
and now it's asking for array one and
arrow two let's open this function
so this is asking for array1
so our array 1 is this range
and our arrow 2 is our spent on studying
when you click ok you'll get the same
value it is 0.98
so there are two ways by which you can
calculate the correlation
that's it i hope you understood this
example
now let's move on to python to see how
you can calculate the correlation using
the python
so here we are on a jupiter notebook
let's see how you can use the jupyter
notebook and python to calculate the
correlation coefficient that is
pearson's correlation coefficient
so first we'll feed the data that we
have used for our excel example
let's start by importing numpy
now
in our data sheet we had the test scores
so we'll write
this co rds goes
and the scores were 95 36 58
95 36
58
97 99 42
97
99 and
42
for the duration of ours we have
6 1 3 5 6 2
6
1
three
five six
two
so we have entered both the data of
scores and ours
now to calculate the correlation
coefficient we'll use the function
corr correlation
coefficient
and will mention both the data sets
that is
scores
and us
now let's run to see if we get the same
value as in excel
so you can see we have the same value of
0.980 as our correlation coefficient and
it matches with our excel data
so in this way you can calculate the
correlation coefficient using python
that's it
we have come to an end to this tutorial
if you like this video don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and hit that
like button
thank you again and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here